faire et guy bedos à vous étiez sur les
barricades non non non non je n'étais
pas sur les barricades je le dis dans
mon cas je l avoue je n'ai pas bien
compris mais 68 g pas je n'ai pas vu
arriver vraiment jamais personne n'avait
vu arriver mais ce vous l'avez vécu j'ai
vécu mais à ma place c'est à dire chez
les saltimbanques et bon je le dis à un
autre moment c'est de ces deux
corporations si éloignées l'une de
l'autre les hommes politiques et les
acteurs c'est incroyable ce que qu'ils
peuvent s'influencer dans ces moments là
et les acteurs se sont mis à parler
comme des hommes politiques
essama en somme vous trouvez qu'ils se
ressemblent beaucoup
oui dans l'un des deux cas c'est moins
grave oui ça n'engage qu'un public assez
reste à chaque soir oui on dit quand on
est un homme politique responsabilité
centre en ça que nous les histrions nous
pouvons avoir peut-être une espèce de de
fibre politique c'est que nous avons le
sens du mensonge et de la vérité
justement parce que nous sommes des
menteurs professionnels et nous savons
assez bien décelé le mensonge des autres
notamment chez les hommes publics
mais en mai 68 j'ai été littéralement
sidéré par ce que il ya eu une confusion
est chez nous lâche et les acteurs c'est
terrible parce que ça devait occuper des
hauts lieux du théâtre du cinéma
non non gelée aux assemblées générales
je me suis laissée enfermer dans la
corporation et je me prenais déjà pour
un homme de gauche
là je me suis senti vraiment débordés
parce que il y avait un petit côté
épuration qui m'a fait très peur parce
que je je suis un homme de gauche qui
déteste les charrettes voyez je veux
dire je n'ai pas je n'aime pas je ne
peux pas jurer que je
je suis un non violent mais mes limites
je vois que ma limite et verbales voilà
comme je le dit un autre moment je joue
la défense il ya même un bon copain qui
occupait le guinio du luxembourg
roger carel dial is a way je vois
proches à ce moment là je m'en occupais
il a dit avec la voile à la disney qu'on
lui connaît je vais occuper les typos
tourner on parie que c'est vrai qu'à ce
moment là on manquait un peu d'humour
notamment à gauche c'est vrai alors il
ya un point commun vos quatre livres me
semble-t-il c'est l'amitié